hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast chemistry and technology
advancements in protein gel
electrophoresis I am jus T O'Rourke of
lab roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by labyrinth and sponsored by
thermo fisher scientific thermo fisher
scientific is the world leader in
serving science with revenues of 17
billion and approximately 50,000
employees in 50 countries our mission is
to enable our customers to make the
world healthier cleaner and safer we
help our customers accelerate life
sciences research solve complex
analytical challenges improve patient
diagnostics and increase laboratory
productivity through our premier brands
thermo scientific applied biosystems
invitrogen Fisher Scientific and unity
lab services we offer an unmatched
combination of innovative technologies
purchasing convenience and comprehensive
support we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window when we have
time to answer a few questions from the
audience today but we'll follow up on
those we do not have time for shortly
you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or carrying this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button lower left I would now like
to introduce today's speaker jun ma
market development manager in the bio
sciences division at thermo fisher
scientific june is the north america
market development manager for protein
biology in immunological systems at
thermo fisher scientific he has a BS in
bio engineering from the University of
California San Diego
in an MBA from the University of
California Los Angeles I will now turn
it over to jun hwa for his presentation
thank you Judy and hello everybody and
welcome to today's session on
improvements of protein gel
electrophoresis both from a chemistry
and technology perspective now many of
you who are doing basic protein research
think that gel electrophoresis is a
pretty basic technique that has not
changed much over the years and though
that is true most continue to perform
these gels and relatively the same
manner they originally learned it in
college or in grad school or perhaps
from the labs in which they work as
postdocs making small tweaks here and
there to these gels making small
improvements along the way so that they
can look at their downstream Western
blotting or gel staining a little bit
better and more improved however there
have been advancements over the years
and protein gels that have differed from
the moments a decade or so ago that have
made protein gel electrophoresis much
more robust and also made a difference
in resolution and detection of your
protein separation and those are the
small improvements and Roger
technological gaps that were wanting to
touch upon today in this session now in
today's session we're going to go
through several things broadly speaking
we'll talk about the types of protein
gel electrophoresis will highlight
specifically SDS page as the
electrophoresis system of choice we'll
go through the different buffer systems
that exist in the world of
electrophoresis as well as the gel
chemistry's that are out there we'll
also talk about these chemical and
technological improvements to gel
electrophoresis touching upon both self
casting gel systems as well as precast
adjel systems as well as Ted cap
rattusses and improvements upon those as
well and finally concluding with the
types of choices and decisions and
conclusions that you can come from
understanding these improvements in gel
electrophoresis
now the types of Dalek pieces are buried
although there is one is predominantly
most popular than others as a quick
overview the basic polyacrylamide gel
which freezes or page gel separates
proteins by their native physical
properties this is sometimes often also
known as native page gel electrophoresis
the most common form however is SDS page
or sodium those syl sulfate page
electrophoresis and this form
electrophoresis eliza's proteins by
coating them with a uniform negative
charge disrupt disrupting the majority
of the non covalent bonds and reducing
their hydrophobicity sds-page treatment
largely remove differences between
proteins in both charge and conformation
making size the main determinant of the
electrophoretically this mobility is
used to determine the approximate lector
weights of the proteins with reference
to the mobility of the stink protein
standards that are in the same exact gel
in addition to sds-page and typical
native page there's also reducing into
natured SDS page where the addition of
DDT or other additives reduce disulfide
bridges to achieve better denaturing as
a whole these are the three major types
of protein gel electrophoresis now as an
overview what happens during SDS page
well you first begin with the protein
itself you're then going to add the SDS
to that proteins the SGS then binds to
the amino acid residues and gives a
uniform maybe of charge as we mentioned
and will keep the protein then against
linearize or denature once it's loaded
onto the gel the protein sample is
loaded along with the lane marker
typically a set of protein standards
that have note the different molecular
weights of your protein samples and then
electric current is applied where the
negative charge allows protein to
migrate towards the cathode N and
separates the gel based upon the
electrophoresis properties now beyond
choosing the type of gel electrophoresis
system that you want to use choosing
right gel percentage also helps in
making sure that you have good and solid
protein gel separations choosing the
right gel percentage is really a
function of the protein size that you're
looking at if you have a relatively
simple single protein application
straight percentages are great for that
they provide the state separations of
protein sizes if you're looking for
proteins for example between the four to
forty kill dalton range a 20-percent gel
will do the trick if you're looking for
proteins around the 10 to 70 range a 12
and a half percent gel will also do the
trick however if your application calls
for a separation of a mixture of
proteins then the gradient gel
percentage is best used and depending on
whether you need to see very low
molecular weights as part of your
separation or larger molecular weight
supplier separations you choose a
different gel percentage gradient that
meets your needs at this time we'd like
to ask you a quick polling question and
regards to the type of gel chemistry you
commonly use in your applications you
use Tris glycine gels distress gels or
Tris acid gels qui sait the time right
now to answer this quick polling
question
you
okay so as related to that polling
question there are various different gel
chemistry's when it comes to sds-page
the most common form of protein gel
electrophoresis these chemistry's
include the most widely used triskele
icing gel chemistry's for small and
medium promo codes and separations and
tris glycine uses traditional landline
buffers in its protein gel
electrophoresis in addition to triskele
icing there's also distress gel
chemistry's which also perform
separations around a small to medium
protein range however there are other
specialty chemistry's that also exists
Tris acetate chemistry's which are
mentioned in the polls help with better
separation along large molecular weight
proteins and tracing gels allow for a
better separation along small molecular
weight proteins in addition to type of
chemistry there are also different types
of buffer systems both continuous and
discontinuous buffer systems in a
continuous buffer system utilizes a same
buffer in the gel and the running buffer
although this is not as popular as the
discontinuous system is still useful the
most commercially available gels however
use discontinuous buffer systems and in
a distant continuous buffer system the
two different gel layers offer different
pore sizes that result in high
resolution of separation as an example
of the types of this continues buffer
systems let's take a look at each one of
them as it relates to the three
chemistry we had mentioned earlier Tris
glycine mistress and tris acetate
interest slicing chemistry's the mixture
includes glycine protein SDS complex and
chloride with the gel operating pH of
9.5 and that's important to note as we
talk about improvements to gel
electrophoresis into this Tris gel
system it's a mixture of mess or locks
buffers protein SDS complexes and
chloride as well however the running
operating pH is seven point 0 a neutral
pH interest acetate it's a mixture of
try seen a protein SDS complex and
assets
with the gel operating pH of 8.1 at this
time we like to take another opportunity
to ask a polling question to the
audience about your experience with your
gel which freezes when it comes to
resolution question is do you ever
experience smiling gels or poor band
separation during your electrophoresis
yes or no
okay thank you so let's take a look at
each one of these chemistry's one at a
time and specifically the two most
popular ones triskele icing and Mistress
chemistry's tris glycine utilizes the
traditional language system it is the
most widely used form of separating gels
using sds-page how great is highly
alkaline is operating pH as we have
mentioned earlier this is limited like
sending running times and gel
instability from the hydrolysis of
polyacrylamide to chrome acid in the
alkaline conditions and although triste
icing is popular this kind of high ph in
its running operation may cause band
distortions a loss of resolution and
artifacts and bands due to protein
degradation alteration in run on the
flip side there is also the best risk
chemistry which operates underneath the
neutral ph condition this neutral ph
condition minimizes the protein
degradation and provides it the
following advantages over lammle systems
it improves the shelf life which extends
the shelf life to 16 months due to
improve gel stability and also due to
the neutral ph it can create sharper
band resolutions and more accurate
results as an example of what this looks
like this particular dataset compares on
the left hand side the invitrogen bolt
gel which is a viscous chemistry gel to
a traditional triskele icing gel on the
right hand side and in it various
different proteins have been loaded
similar proteins for you to forage lane
as you can see from the left hand side
with the distress bolt gel the bands are
relatively sharp and clean on the right
hand side the trust icing gels the bands
are a little bit more separated and
different degradation events have
occurred now oftentimes the protein
degradation that happens with non
neutral ph chemistry's are not as
dramatic as an example we show here more
often than not it shows up in the few
stands or smeared bands and if you've
ever experienced those particular
that's using at risk isenj l it could be
due to the new to the high ph of at-risk
isenj l and what happened there is that
the protein degradation event occurred
in varying degrees and those varying
degrees of degradation had been seared
and separated out as the gel progressed
now as far as options beyond chemistry
and buffer conditions there is also a
choice between self casting options and
precast gel options and the materials
that are needed for both are different
mainly because of the amount of work
that goes into each one with the self
cast of gel option you will need on only
a casting apparatus the acrylamide the
team at ApS staffing resolving buffers
gel running buffers as well as a running
tain you also need the time to be able
to perform the cell cast itself the pros
of course are that you get a fresh gel
each time which is advantageous however
it is a lot of time and effort there's
casting apparatus failures just by scene
is the predominant main choice in
chemistry and single percentages are
typically the only way the only types of
gels and you can cast inconsistency in
the gel cats can also result in
resolution inconsistencies on the flip
side with precast you options you simply
need the precast gel product running
buffers and the gel tank the pros of
precast joke product is it's more
consistent results and sharper bands due
to consistent manufacturing practices of
the companies that offer them and the
choice of different chemistries also
exists not only in straight percentages
but also in gradient percentages however
there is a con which is a higher
consumable cost for the researcher what
we like to do now is to ask another
polling question to the audience as it
relates to the type of gels that you
typically do do you perform self casting
gels or you perform precast gels
now you may be considering that self
casting gels is a typical process that
you go undergo protein electrophoresis
or precast shows maybe your typical
process but we want to make sure that
you understand that there have been made
improvements made to build self casting
gels and precast gels and we'll go into
each one of them now improving upon self
casting gels begins with the primary
issues that a user could potentially see
when passing their own gels and a
primary issue that most customers see is
that the casting apparatus fails and
this exhibit 'add in either leaking or
the breaking of the apparatus itself the
glass plates which are utilizing the
systems often chip or crack which can
lead to leaks the foam inserts or the
manner in which the gel plates are seal
may deteriorate over time causing leaks
and this all results in a waste of
effort and time in exhibit exemplified
in to be pouring of a new gel now our
nitrogen sure cast hand cast system
which recently came out this year
exhibits a couple of features that help
solve for these problems number one it
has a more durable reusable glass plate
it's sticker and more damage resistant
think what current suppliers offer
hitting upon one of the major needs that
the customers have when it comes to be
pouring gels it's up to 20 times more
durable in that respect also it's a
hundred percent of the free due to the
wide silicone face-to-face sealing
method that we've employed which
provides even pressure seals across all
three sides of the plate and increases
seal durability over time meaning to
less deterioration and therefore fewer
leaks in addition to the apparatus
improvements his shirt cast hand cast
reagents are all stored at room
temperature which can provide additional
benefits and that applies to not only
the team at APs and both tackling and
resolving buffers but can also apply to
the forty percent of krill alive which
is quite unique why is this better you
may ask well it begins
first with making sure that all the
casting agents are at the same
temperature when you begin casting your
gels with all the reagents at the same
room temperature the temperature effects
and polymerization rates are reduced
having everything at the same
temperature means you won't have to
spend time bringing all the region's up
to the same temperature we begin casting
your gels a lot sooner also with
everything at 4 degrees Celsius of room
temperature easier and safer storage is
is is achievable without having to bring
everything up to the same temperature at
this highly like to ask another polling
question to the audience do you wish you
could have loaded more samples into your
gels yes or no
in addition to self casting improvements
there have also been improvements to pre
casual options and related to the
previous polling questions when the
primary customer needs when it comes to
precast gels isn't need to load more
samples into their wells oftentimes
customers make a choice there between
the thickness of the jello itself either
one point 0 millimeter moving to 1.5
millimeter and this is a need for
customers especially those performing
gel electrophoresis on low abundance
protein samples or perhaps antibodies
that have a poor or weak affinity and
therefore resulting in poor protein
signal at the back end Western blot poor
gel resolution can also be a primary
issue with customers especially those
utilizing traditional lammle buffer
conditions with the impeachment no vex
wedge walt risk isenj l's we try to
solve for some of those problems first
namely we have a proprietary wedge well
shaped gel which allows you to load up
to 60 microliters of sample per well
this well as exhibited by the image on
the right is in a triangular wedge shape
well and available in these particular
MIDI gels in addition the probe and
resolution and quality has been improved
as well to minimize the smiling effects
and distortion that you typically see
with triskele icing gels in this data
set we try to explain what exactly it
means to have a wedge well when it comes
to your protein gel separation results
on the left hand side is the Nomex wedge
ultra slicing ten world gels along with
the various different volumes of sample
loaded into each well on the right hand
side is a typical Tris glycine gel from
competing supplier loaded with the same
sample volumes of 20 30 40 50 and 60
microliters as you can see with the no
vex wedge will try slicing gel even at
60 microliters skipping wells in between
samples you do not see spillover in the
separation of the
itself however on typical standard well
triskele icing gels you see spillover
effects happening in and around the 50
microliter loading volume and the 60
microliter bar loading broadening thus
showing that the milled extra slicing
wedge one gel can load all the way up to
60 microliters in at ala moana format
without spilled over into subsequent
lanes from a resolution perspective the
gnome extra sky seen wedge full gel has
been shown to have minimized smiling
distortion effects compared to other
suppliers crystallizing gels as
exhibited here in this data set in
addition to providing improvements due
to larger load volumes there's also been
improvements that have been made due to
band resolutions as a result of gel
chemistry's as we had mentioned earlier
in the presentation as well as
improvements on gel running times and
the particular product that from our
company that we want to be able to
exhibit today is the imbue trogen and
bolt mistress gels it's neutral pH
mistress chemistry preserved the protein
integrity with the neutral pH as we had
mentioned and offers a unique buffer
formulation that eliminates the smiles
and poor resolution seen on traditional
tryst icing gels in addition the bolt
mistress gels also contain the wedge
well shaped wells easily allowing for up
to 60 microliters of sample load volume
in a 10 well format but in addition to
these two features the bolt gel can also
be run in as quickly as 22 minutes at
200 volts here similarly to the Novack's
went well jel we loaded 40 50 55 60 and
even up to 70 microliters of sample in a
boat 10 well gel as compared to
competitors typical welch typical
standard well jel going up to 40
microliters and similarly to the wedge
well shape we do not see spillover in
the adjacent lanes for the bolt gel
unlike standard well gels we do see
still over thus showing that the bowl
gel
and it can contain up to 60 or more
microliters of road volume here's the
same piece of data that we showed
earlier exemplifying the difference
between the mistress neutral ph gel
chemistry versus a traditional Christian
gel chemistry the bolt mistress gel
chemistry with the neutral pH minimizes
protein degradation zin run leading to
more sharp and better resolutions in
your gel electrophoresis in this data
set we perform the Western blot using
the bulk gel on the top and a
competitor's Chris Tyson gel and a
typical gel stain on the bottom and a
competitor's chris ison gel on the
bottom as well and this again
exemplifies how a mistress neutral ph
along with the mutagen manufacturing
process provides a much more consistent
and publishable result with minimized
smiling distortions in the bands of the
gel electrophoresis furthermore
improving upon pretty casual options we
also have the mission new page novex
mistress protein gel also including the
neutral ph gel chemistry which preserves
protein integrity with the neutral ph as
well as fast sharp band resolution runs
in as little as 30 minutes at 200 volts
here is a piece of data comparing on the
left the new page mistress gel with the
suppliers crystallizing gel again
showing that better resolution and
better publishable band results can be
achieved with the district's new tral ph
chemistry's so in summary for precast
options we presented today the triskele
icing no vex wedge well and tris glycine
options both mistress and you page
mistress options and for the self
casting jaw option we have induced
ensure cast hand cast apparatus as well
as the shirt cast hand cast reagents in
addition to these particular gel options
we also offer Chris acetate
options for larger molecular weight
separations try seeing options for low
molecular weight separations and various
other chemistry's such as a native page
for typical page electrophoresis in
addition to the provements on gel
electrophoresis gels there are also been
improvements on protein gel
electrophoresis tank apparatuses primary
user issues for standard gel tanks
including a back-to-back design which
makes it difficult to load samples
easily without turning to tank around
wasted gel writing buffers for those who
want to run a single gel under tanka
privacy's difficulties in seeing the gel
progression and the ladder progression
in run due to clarity of the plastic
utilized and difficult to judge the
buffer fill volumes when the tank when
the tank is full in that capacity the
invention mini gel team makes subtle yet
significant improvements to the user
experience when it comes to gel
apparatus we have simultaneous
visualization of both gels in a
streamlined side-by-side tank
configuration we allow for easy sample
loading through a forward-facing well
configuration less running buffer is
required especially when you're running
only a single gel you can load only one
chamber at a time if you wish the white
background on the tank allows for easy
and simple monitoring the pre-stained
ladders and standard loaded onto the gel
and spilled over chambers on the edges
around for consistent and precise buffer
fill lines at this time we would like to
ask an additional polling question to
the audience how fast would you ideally
like your gels to run under 30 minutes
between 30 and 60 minutes or over 60
minutes
as a summary of running conditions on
the mini gel tank we like to exhibit a
couple of things the note well the bolt
and new page mistress chemistry gels can
run in under 60 minutes with the bolt
gel running underneath mess running
buffer conditions as low as 20 to 22
minutes underneath the mops running
condition in as low as 35 minutes the
new page mistress chemistry's hit run as
low as 30 minutes at 200 volts utilizing
a mess running buffer and as low as 4 to
2 minutes utilizing the mops running
buffer typical triste icing gels can run
anywhere between 25 to 40 minutes or an
hour and hour and a half plus depending
on the nature or native state running
condition typical Tris acetate gels can
run between 50 to 100 minutes again
depending on to the nature or native
state running conditions as a summary to
choose which gel type is best for you
it's important to understand whether or
not you want to run nature the nature
present conditions or native running
conditions in a denatured separation
your first choice is choose between
molecular weight sizes we had mentioned
earlier on that if you're looking at a
low molecular weight protein and you
want to resolve in among other low
molecular weight proteins a try some gel
would be your best choice if however
you're looking at a higher molecular
weight protein mix those about 200
kelvins buttress acid a gel would be the
best gel of choice those who are looking
at proteins in the middle or the most
broad range of molecular weights between
20 and two hundred kilovolts a typical
triste glycine or distress gel would be
your good would be your gel choice but
between the two
understanding how much sample you want
the load onto your gel could make a
difference in your ultimate result and
choosing a Ledge well shaped gel either
the novex wedge war gel from a nitrogen
or the bolt went well gel will allow you
to load up to 60 microliters of wrong
name also if your results a result if
your job results result in searing or
smiling effects choosing a bit stressed
neutral pH chemistry could minimize
those results as well in a native
separation you will be able to choose
between molecular weights isoelectric
points and proteus activity as your
predominant choices of protein gels so
the key takeaways today from this
session is the most widely used
chemistry is Tris lysine because it has
no special running buffers however it
can lead to certain degradation of the
proteins in running that is where a
neutral pH system such as the best risk
chemistry's were allowed to minimize no
protein degradation improve gel results
and also improve running times hi sample
load volumes can also be achieved using
traditional triste Isaac chemistry's
such as the mill Beck's wedge ultra
slicing gels or mistress gel chemistry
with the bolt mistress plots Jones if
you'd like to learn more about protein
electrophoresis or downstream Western
detection or transfer we have various
technical handbooks at your disposal for
both separate transfer and detect of the
western work for them the various URLs
are provided here and are free for you
to be able downloading and that
concludes this session today on protein
gel electrophoresis improvements there
any questions we'll go ahead and open it
up for Q&A session thank you
thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I'd like
to run our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window in our first
question is if you see diffuse bands in
the stain is it always due to the gel
chemistry so the answer to that is no
although we've shown today during the
presentation that gel chemistry's can
lead to better results we had shown the
difference between the degradation in
crystallizing gels versus mistress gels
gel chemistry is not the only reason why
you would see a diffuse ban on a gel
stain for example oftentimes the most
common reason is the amount of protein
that's actually loaded into the gel
itself sometimes Logan too much protein
can lead to smearing or fat bands that
will not resolve well in a protein gel
and although all the times most
researchers and users do not know how
much actual protein is in their sample
if they do see a rather diffuse van show
up in a gel chemistry that they're used
to using and have good separations
typically reducing the amount of protein
sample wrote it onto the gel can solve
for that especially if you already have
a very well-defined signal that this
could actually sharpen up your jello
results there was a difference in
running times between mess and mops for
the mistress gels what's the difference
there so yes yes there was a difference
there between vests in March and you saw
it in both the bulk gels the new page
gels in the end
and and and there were quite not quite
significant but there were at least a
few ten minutes here and there i believe
the bold gels you can run the mess
running buffering of those 22 minutes
versus 35 minutes of mops with the new
page gel as you can run at gel as low as
30 minutes i believe this let's all as
42 minutes with the mops typically this
decision between mess and mops comes
down to the molecular weight of the
protein itself mops will slow down that
gel run and by slowing down the gel run
it achieves better separation at the mid
to large molecular weight range mess is
much better for smaller molecular weight
proteins and so that's typically the
difference in choice when users have to
decide between a mess or box running
buffer
are the which will gels all 16 micro
litre well capacity I know they're there
they are not we had shown examples of
data today that had the 60 microliter
example set at the 10 well capacity and
so the maximum load capacity for ten
well gels are 60 microliters however if
you are using larger number of wells
such as a 12-well or 15 well mini gel
just from common sense why's the well
size is going to be a lot smaller from
the width the width perspective and so
you're going to have a lower maximum
rolling volume however despite the fact
that that happens at the 12 to 15 well
jel it's still a larger load volume
compared to a standard well jel itself
for example for the 12 load gel the
maximum loading capacity of a wedge well
is forty five microliters and if you
compare that to a standard capacity of
about twenty five microliters for a one
millimeter thickness gel or 37
microliters for a 1.5 millimeter gel a
45 micro liter capacity on a one
millimeter jail for 12 well Joe is still
much larger so even though it's much
smaller for larger number of wells it
still is much larger than a standard
where gel would be able to provide you
why did the LAN lead Tris glycine gels
of a short shelf life of about three
months um so the typical triskele icing
gel if you make it yourself definitely
has a short shelf life abroad trip about
three months there have been various
different additives added to
commercially made crystal ice and gels
allowed to be a lot longer in shelf life
but not as long as a mistress neutral pH
gel and and that's exactly the main
reasons why it's the ph of the chemistry
itself and the basic ph levels the
chrome lights slowly hydrolyzes and
formed the acrylic acid over time which
interferes with the proper of protein
separation as we have seen into actual
gel results but this also leads to a
much this this instability over time
allows for a much lower shelf life if
you were to make it yourself as a fresh
gel obviously but additives have been
created to be able to extend the shelf
life of traditional and exercising gels
and no vex wedge 10 Tristan icing gels
for example have a 12 month shelf life
so not all crystallizing gels have a
short shelf life especially but more and
more especially the ones that we make on
your own
okay we have time for one last question
questions we did not have time for today
will be addressed after the presentation
I am interested in peptide separation
short lengths of molecular weights of
800 Dalton's what gel is suitable for
this so as we had mentioned in the
presentation your gel choice can be
locally the pendant so for small short
lengths of molecular weight such as that
where it's 800 Dalton's you may want to
try the try some gel chemistry which
allows for the separation of the lower
low molecular weight proteins to be at a
larger percentage of the total gel wing
so that allows you to separate out the
low unlike awaits better so that you can
see sharper resolutions between these
local ways whereas in a standard broad
molecular weight gel such as a tryst
glycine gel or biz Tris gel the low and
high end kill Dalton or microwave
proteins will be much more compact in
its run and it's in its resolution so
it's a little bit harder for you to
resolve out various different peptides
of small molecular weight length
similarly with the high molecular weight
proteins we recommended at risk acetate
gel chemistry because what it will do is
it will actually spread out the high
molecular weights along a larger
percentage of the gel so you actually
are able to resolve better higher
molecular weight proteins above 200
Kelvin so for smaller short lengths as
the question that asks the try seen gel
is the best for larger molecule weights
we recommend Tris acetate and for
everybody that's in between a standard
risk lysine rupestris gel will do the
trick
I would like to once again thank you mom
for his presentation do you have any
final comments you guys coming on to the
event today and we appreciate you guys
coming on to the event and we hope you
enjoyed the rest of the day's events
thank you I would also like to thank our
sponsor thermo fisher scientific for
making today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
June twenty-eighth 2017 you will receive
an email from lab roots alerting you
when this webcast will be available for
replay we invite you to afford that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event see you
next time goodbye